hi i'm nicholas paul breiswitz the
director of development here at the long
now foundation
and i want to begin tonight's program by
letting you know how much we appreciate
your support for our work
long now is a non-profit organization
and every one of our projects and
programs is entirely funded by members
and donors like you
so thank you for helping us foster
long-term thinking
we believe that civilization scale
challenges call for this kind of
civilization scale thinking
and this has been an especially
challenging year for so many people
and so many organizations including ours
if you're able please consider making a
special donation to our annual
fundraising campaign
you can make an online donation in just
minutes by visiting longnow.org
support by making a tax deductible gift
to the long now foundation
you'll not only be helping an
organization directly affected by this
civilization scale challenge
but you'll be helping us help everyone
get better at addressing all such
civilization scale challenges
learn more at longnow.org support and
please don't forget to ask your employer
if they have a charitable gift matching
program that could double
or even triple your impact on long-term
thinking thank you again for all your
support
enjoy the seminar hello i'm alexander
rose the executive director here at long
now
we are coming to you from the interval
here in san francisco where james nestor
and i will watch the pre-recorded talk
with you all
and stay on to answer questions
afterward many of you may remember james
from his talk he gave here at the
interval
on the way humans can hold their breath
for tens of minutes at a time
and how that ability came from our
underwater ancestry
in his most recent book james takes us
on a deep dive in a very different way
into the way that we actually breathe
and how that has been affected by modern
agriculture
and dentistry welcome james nester
thank you xander several years ago i
came here and spoke at the long now
foundation about the human connection to
the ocean
i talked about magnetoreception this
kind of
natural form of gps that allows sharks
and whales and even
humans to navigate the world without a
map
i talked about echolocation and how
cetaceans and people too
can actually see without ever opening
our eyes
and i talked about these people
freedivers athletes who had honed the
mammalian dive reflexes that all marine
mammals share
and use them to dive hundreds of feet
deep on a single breath of air
when i asked these free divers how they
could do what they did
they told me it was easy anyone in
reasonable health could do it
all you had to do was master the art of
breathing
it was only by really learning how to
breathe that we could survive
underwater for five six seven eight
minutes
at a time and plummet to such extreme
depths
but these free divers told me something
else they told me that the art of
breathing
extended beyond just deep diving they
told me about
a man who'd been injected with the
bacterial endotoxin e coli
then breathed in a rhythmic pattern to
stimulate his immune system
and destroy the toxins within minutes
they told me about a woman who'd
overcome decades of autoimmune diseases
by simply changing the way she breathed
and they told me about an 85 year old
who'd rediscovered an ancient practice
to super
heat himself and sit in the snow for
hours
without ever getting hypothermia or
frostbite
again using only his breath all of this
sounded insane of course
and i look forward to finding these
charlatans and exposing them
but as i began digging more deeply into
the art of breathing after i spent
months and months
reading through scientific studies and
talking to experts in the field
i discovered that these impossible
stories were
actually true breathing was this
extraordinary tool
we could all use to hack into otherwise
autonomic functions
we could breathe in ways to control our
nervous system shift our brain states
even correct our skelecature each of us
takes in about 30 pounds of air
in and out of our bodies every single
day far more than we eat and drink
the new science of breathing was showing
us that how we took in
all of that air and how we exhaled it
determined
so much of our health our lifespan
and our human potential how we breathe
was in many ways as important as what we
ate or how much we exercised
it really was a missing pillar of health
the experts i began working with
told me something else that most of us
are breathing all wrong
now i've been breathing my whole life as
have all of you
and i thought i've been doing it well
enough after all i'm still here
i'm still alive but breathing it turns
out
is not a binary practice it's not just
if we do it or if we don't do it it's
how we do it that's so
important and so many of us have
forgotten how to breathe healthily
about nine percent of the us population
suffers from asthma
about 16 million of us suffer from copd
it's the third
leading cause of death about half of a
snore about 20 percent of us suffer from
nightly exfixiation known as sleep apnea
this list goes on and on and on
these respiratory problems and other
poor breathing habits
can exacerbate or in some cases cause
a laundry list of serious health issues
increased risk of stroke adhd heart
disease there were even links between
poor breathing and metabolic problems
like diabetes so how did this happen
how have humans become so divorced from
our most
basic biological function the answers i
was told
could be found in ancient human skulls
it turns out that the pathway through
which humans take in
and exhale air has changed dramatically
in the past few centuries
because the human face has dramatically
changed over the past few centuries
and for the worst wait what i'd always
learned in school that evolution is a
straight line forward of progress
it's all about survival of the fittest
and darwinism and all that
but as i waded deeper into this research
i learned that that
interpretation of evolution is wrong
evolution means
change and life can change for better
or for worse take for instance the
concept of natural selection
natural selection does not produce
organisms
perfectly suited to their environments
instead
natural selection produces a range of
traits
that allow a species to be good enough
to survive
we just need to be good enough to pass
on our genes
to the next generation this helps
explain why humans have grown more obese
why we've grown more myopic
why we've grown more allergic depressed
and fragile
none of these traits are of any benefit
to us they aren't making us stronger
or faster or more resilient but at the
same time
they aren't really stopping us from
breeding harvard
anthropologist daniel lieberman coined a
name
for this kind of regressive change he
called it dis
evolution and to a large extent this
dis-evolution
explains why humans have also become
such poor breathers
in other words we weren't always this
way
just a few centuries ago our mouths and
our sinuses and our airways
were vastly different they allowed us in
many ways
to breathe more easily i visited the
museum of archaeology and anthropology
at the university of pennsylvania to see
how we changed
the museum contains one of the largest
collections of pre-industrial skulls
in the world the lead curator there
janet monge
showed me a few dozen different ancient
human skulls
and every single one of them had these
powerful jaws these wide faces and these
broad mouths
monge pointed out something else these
skulls had perfect teeth
the skull you see here is not some
rarity
monge told me that she'd never seen a
hunter gather
with crooked teeth not one of them
this was true for all humans all over
the world in india
africa china europe south america and
more
the further back in time you went to 5
000 years old
50 000 years old 150 000 years old you'd
see
even more powerful jaws even wider nasal
passages
even bigger mouths you'd see universally
perfectly straight teeth here's the jaw
of one of the oldest
human skulls it's about 300 000 years
old notice its teeth
perfectly straight even older a million
years ago
our skulls look like this notice the
huge
nasal cavity here this very wide and
powerful
forward-growing face again straight
teeth
the skull you are seeing now is about 8
000 years old
still this very large powerful jaw
forward growing face
straight teeth now look at how our
skulls look about 2 000 years ago
notice how much smaller the jaw is
getting how the face is more narrow
still straight teeth but things are
getting tighter
here is how we look today almost like
another species
very narrow jaw small mouth very slender
face
with a mouth is small teeth no longer
fit
they have to fight for space so they
grow in crooked
ninety percent of us now have some sort
of misalignment
or malocclusion in our teeth this is why
we need extractions and braces and
headgear and all that
our teeth no longer fit in our two small
mouths
there's another problem in having a
mouth that's too small
for its face it's given humans a
different kind of profile
what you're seeing now is a typical
profile of an ancient skull
almost every single skull measured at
the museum of archaeology
and anthropology was found to be ahead
of that perpendicular line
what's called a prognathic profile but
in the last 300
400 years our profiles have been
receding
90 of the human population now has a
face that grows
behind that perpendicular line called a
retrognathic profile
there's a more serious issue to having
this retrognathic profile
than just aesthetics it's shrunken our
airways
a smaller mouth and flatter face means
less room to breathe
this is why so many of us have such a
hard time getting air in and out of our
bodies
beyond a few breeds of bulls pugs or
other
highly inbred brachycephalic dogs
modern humans are the only species to
consistently
share these traits we are perhaps the
only mammals
in the history of life on earth to have
chronically crooked teeth
these researchers told me something else
if i didn't believe
any of this all i needed to do was look
at animals
in the wild so of course i did i looked
at chimps
they all have perfectly straight teeth i
looked at berbaraf mccox
straight teeth dolphins straight teeth i
looked at my mutt of a dog
straight teeth meanwhile this is what
we're stuck with
and if we don't do anything about it we
can end up looking like this
this is how we became the worst
breathers in the animal kingdom
so much for survival of the fittest
all of this brings up a larger question
why why did this happen to us and what
caused it
how could our mouths shrink and airways
become so obstructed
so quickly i looked to the national
institutes of health for answers they
provided a very clear answer
they said that crooked teeth were mostly
inherited
we get them from our parents great
but that does nothing to explain why our
ancestors
just a few hundred years ago were so
well formed
and why the vast majority of us today
are so messed up
i became pretty obsessed with tracking
this down
and so i wanted to see more skulls
specifically i wanted to see the turning
point
when our faces fell apart on a mass
scale
i wanted to do this to really get my
head around this subject
and in order to do this i needed to get
my hands on some skulls
old ones and lots of them i called some
friends
at a foundation which shall remain
nameless
the long mouth foundation and one of
them told me
my best chance of stumbling upon a large
trove of centuries-old skulls
was to fly to paris and crawl 60 feet
below
the garden of luxembourg down there
within
170 miles of old limestone quarries
was one of the largest graveyards on
earth
six million skeletons dating back from a
couple thousand years
to a couple hundred years so i arrived
in paris and was put in contact
with some freelance urban explorers
there were three women in pantsuits and
they called themselves cataphiles
they'd spent years mapping out the
underground passageways
and claimed to know the location of an
ancient ossuary
filled with a few thousand victims of a
cholera epidemic
that ravaged paris in 1832
this was the time in western history
when small mouths
crooked teeth and obstructed airways
became the norm
throughout paris and much of
industrialized europe
these cataphiles had spent countless
days and nights exploring
where there were no tourists no
descriptive plaques no ropes
no lights and no rules where nothing was
off limits
to be clear this wasn't the most legal
thing i've ever done
after an hour of climbing and digging
through caves and hallways
we reached an enormous pile of fibulas
ribs and jaws
bones all of them human and skulls
hundreds and hundreds of them i'll admit
i was very much a novice at inspecting
skeletons
but there really was a clear difference
in the shape and symmetry of these
skulls from the 1800s
compared to the hunter gatherers in
other ancient
indigenous populations i'd seen before
these were the patient
zeros the modern obstructive face i left
paris mildly haunted to think that we've
been
so perfect for so long and then just
devastated by this diss evolution in a
relative
blink of an eye but then again
why what was it that changed in the
1800s
to cause all of this damage i still
didn't know
and i wasn't the first person to wonder
turned out that dozens of scientists
from all over the world have been asking
the same question
for hundreds of years i started pouring
through their research
trying to piece together the story of
our breathing
and how it all went so wrong for much of
the past two millennia
the commonly held belief was that
disease deformities
and other ailments were caused by some
sort of toxic
exposure of some noxious and dirty stuff
infiltrating our bodies and making us
sick
the ancient romans had a name for it
they called it miasma
which meant bad air they believed miasma
emanated from the ground
or from the breath of snakes and other
poisonous animals
if we were exposed to too much of it we
might get a skin disease or bubonic
plague maybe we'd get
leprosy or crooked teeth so human
sickness was
spread through these huge clouds of
poisonous air
this miasma theory stuck around until
around
the late 1700s when a dutch drape shop
owner
named anthony van leeuwenhoek began
collecting glass
lenses in a metal tube constructing the
first super powerful microscope
lewinhock intended to use this device to
inspect the thread he was selling in his
shop
but after a while he got curious began
inspecting other stuff
skin sperm wood pulp insects and rain
water
he noticed something extraordinary
festering within substances were these
little
organisms he called them little animals
or animolecules lewinhock determined
that
yes our bodies were being infiltrated by
toxins
and these substances were making us sick
perhaps even deforming us
but it wasn't miasma it was these little
evil animolecules they would later get a
different name
we would call them germs so germ
paranoia quickly spread throughout
europe
people began covering their mouths and
their bodies and their windows
anything to keep these little beasts
away
but no matter how well populations clean
themselves
no matter how many face masks they wore
people kept getting sick and even
stranger
whole populations started getting sick
with new diseases
nobody had ever seen before that few
had even heard of city dwellers in
england were among the hardest hit
in the 16 and 1700s tens of thousands of
children
men and women began suffering from
bendable bones
babies were born that couldn't sit up or
move
they couldn't really hold their heads up
or even crawl
many had deformed jaws and mouths and
had difficulty just getting a breath
in and out one doctor at the time wrote
their bones were flexible like wax that
is rather
liquid so that the flabby and toneless
legs
scarcely sustain the weight of the
superimposed body
this new disease seemed to affect the
rich more than the poor
king charles of england suffered from it
later his daughter would die of it
deformities of the bones became so
common that the condition would be
referred to
as the english disease it would later be
called
rickets the king blamed ricketts on
britain's
damp climate but britain's climate
hadn't changed it was as damp and dreary
and awful
as it had always been what had changed
was the english diet around this time at
the dawn of the industrial age
a whole host of new technologies were
developed to process food more quickly
and cheaply
roller mills and later steam mills
ripped the germ and bran
from wheat leaving only a soft white
flour
meats and fruits and vegetables were
canned and bottled
sugar which was once a prized commodity
of the wealthy
became increasingly common and
inexpensive
for the first time in human history
humans could spend their entire lives
eating
nothing but processed food nothing fresh
nothing raw nothing natural and millions
did
and as they did millions became sick
with new
mysterious ailments all the while the
human face
began rapidly deteriorating mouths
shrank
and facial bones grew stunted dental
disease
became common in the incidence of
crooked teeth and jaws
increased tenfold our mouths got so
bad so overcrowded that it became common
to have teeth removed
altogether these maladies affected
not just england but cities throughout
continental europe really
anyone who subsisted on this new diet
bottled
processed industrialized food meanwhile
while all of this awfulness was going on
in continental europe
people living in asia were suffering
from yet another entirely new
and strange disease it too started with
a shortness of breath
then a numbness would take over the
hands and feet
legs would become paralyzed the mouth
would become grossly deformed and teeth
would fall out
this disease was called beriberi named
after the sri lankan
senelese words for week week or i cannot
i cannot
said twice to add emphasis by the early
19th century
barry berry was responsible for 35
of all sicknesses in asia a quarter of
the japanese
navy was afflicted and more than a
million people in the region would
die like ricketts it too was believed to
have been spread
by germs but eventually researchers
found the real culprit
once again it was industrialized food
advances in industrial milling made it
quick and cost
effective to remove the germ and bran
from rice leaving only the starchy white
seed
white rice was considered better tasting
and of higher quality
than the brown chewy pre-milled variety
it quickly
became the staple of asian diets but
this white rice was also deforming
people and making
them sick what was making everyone so
sick wasn't something
in the rice it wasn't germs it was what
the rice was
lacking beriberi was a disease of
deficiency
the bran and germ of rice contain
something called
thiamin thiamin would later be called a
vital amine
or vitamin it turned out that rice bran
and germ was a rich source of vitamins
specifically vitamin b
without sufficient levels of b the
muscles and nerves can't function
properly
teeth would become crooked and mouths
would deform
breathing would become labored the exact
ingredient removed during industrial
milling
was vitamin b ricketts was also
a disease of deficiency but the missing
ingredient causing all of those
bendable bones and mashed mouths was
vitamin
d the richest forms of vitamin d
were found in butter fish oils or suet
all foods that had been removed in the
modern diet
animal bodies can also make vitamin d
but they need regular exposure to
sunlight
in smoggy soot-filled london and other
industrialized cities throughout europe
sunlight was in short supply and even
when the sun
did shine modesty required that
populations be covered
from head to toe by the late 1800s and
early 1900s
vitamins b c and d were distributed via
supplements
juices or other nutrient-rich sources
incidents of beriberi throughout asia
quickly plummeted
and practically disappeared as did
ricketts
this was the age of vitamins one of the
greatest revolutions in medical history
this new understanding of nutrition
enabled us
to blunt then almost entirely kill off
so many epidemics which had plagued
humans for hundreds and hundreds of
years
hooray for vitamins and yet something
wasn't
quite right no matter how much orange
juice we drank
no matter how much sun exposure we got
our mouths
just kept getting smaller and smaller
our teeth kept growing more crooked and
our breeding became
more obstructed and labored by the 1920s
a cincinnati-based dentist and
researcher by the name of weston price
was seeing it firsthand each new
generation of kids he treated
were suffering from worse and worse
dental disease and crooked teeth
price's own son would die after a dental
procedure
and still nobody knew why price
dedicated the rest of his life to
finding out
but price took a different approach
working alongside a national geographic
researcher and explorer
price compiled more than 15 000 print
photographs
more than 4 000 slides he compiled
saliva and food samples and a library of
detailed notes
the same story played out no matter
where he went
societies that had replaced their
traditional diet with industrialized
foods
suffered up to 10 times more cavities
severely crooked teeth
obstructed airways respiratory issues
and overall
poorer health the modern diets were all
the same
white flour white rice jam sweetened
juice canned vegetables and processed
meats
the traditional diets were all different
he traveled to the swiss alps and
visited villages where the locals
ate a diet that consisted almost
entirely of hand-milled bread and
homemade
raw milk cheese he traveled to the
scottish isles
where the populations ate mostly fish
and oatmeal
to alaska where communities subsisted
almost entirely
on seal fish and lichen deep inside
melanesia islands he found tribes whose
meals consisted of pumpkins
pawpaws coconut crabs and sometimes
long pigs also known as humans
some cultures ate nothing but meat while
others were mostly vegetarian
some relied primarily on homemade cheese
while others consumed no dairy at all
their teeth were almost always perfect
their mouths were exceptionally wide
their nasal apertures broad
they suffered from few if any cavities
in dental disease
respiratory problems like asthma or even
tuberculosis
price reported were practically
non-existent
while the foods in these diets may have
all varied
they all contained the same high amounts
of vitamins and minerals
from one and a half to 50 times that of
modern diets
all of them price became convinced that
the cause of our shrinking mouths and
obstructive airways
was deficiencies not just in b
or c or d but of all essential vitamins
vitamins after all often work in
symbiosis
one needs the other to be effective this
explained why supplements could be
useless
unless they were in the presence of
other supplements we needed the full
spectrum
to develop strong bones throughout the
body especially
in the mouth and face by 1939
price published nutrition and physical
degeneration
a 500-page doorstop of data
that he collected during his travels it
was
a quote masterpiece of research
according to the canadian
medical association journal ernest
houghton
a harvard professor called it one of the
ethical pieces of research
but others hated it they couldn't
comprehend
that these so-called primitive people
had somehow shared in systems of health
that were far superior than those in the
modern world
in the end price turned out only to be
half right
yes vitamin deficiencies might explain
why so many people
eating industrialized foods were sick
but they couldn't fully explain
the sudden and extreme shrinking of the
mouth
and the blocking of airways that had
swept through modern societies
even if our ancestors consumed a full
spectrum of vitamins and minerals
every day mouths would very likely still
grow
too small what was true for our
ancestors was also true for us
because the problem had less to do with
what we were eating
than how we ate it chewing
it was the constant stress of chewing
that was lacking from our diets
not specifically vitamins a b c or d
95 of the industrialized diet
was soft our ancient ancestors chewed
for hours a day
every day because they chewed so much
their mouths their teeth
their throats and their faces grew to be
wide and strong
and pronounced this larger mouth
with straighter teeth allowed them to
breathe more easily
food in industrialized societies was so
processed
that it hardly required any chewing at
all
here's some of the industrialized mush
that i grew up eating
yes of course i had extractions yes of
course i need braces and headgear and
everything else
here's the typical modern american diet
today
cheese sauces baked goods spaghetti
fried roots
it's all soft even what's considered
healthy foods
smoothies yogurt avocados
oatmeal it's all soft healthy chewing
starts in infancy the chewing and
sucking stress required for
breastfeeding
exercises the masseter and other facial
muscles
and stimulates more bone growth allowing
for that
upper palate to drop which leads to
wider airways
tell a few hundred years ago mothers
would breastfeed infants
up to two to four years sometimes even
longer
the more time infants spent chewing and
sucking
the more they'd increase their chances
of breathing better
later on in life with industrialization
came bottle feeding and baby formula
soon in many societies
infants were hardly breastfed at all now
dozens and dozens of studies in the past
two decades have supported this claim
they've shown lower incidence of snoring
and sleep apnea
in infants who were breastfed longer
versus those who were bottle-fed
this is why so many of the skulls that
i'd examined in the museum of
archaeology
and anthropology that i'd seen at the
paris quarries
this is why they had narrow faces and
crooked teeth
it's one of the main reasons why so many
of us today
are chronically stuffed up why our
airways are clogged
why we need sprays and pills and surgery
just to get a fresh breath of air a
couple weeks ago i was corresponding
with dr
kevin boyd he's a pediatric dentist and
biological anthropologist in chicago
boyd has spent years working with dr
marianna evans at the university of
pennsylvania
trying to more deeply understand how our
mouths have changed through the lack of
chewing
and how this has changed our breathing
and our health
they've spent a lot of time examining
fetal skulls
boyd shared with me some of his research
here are some pre-industrial fetal
skulls from around
two to three hundred years ago these
fetuses
were from around 18 to 32 weeks old
you'll notice that profile that pronatic
growth that pronounced jaw that wider
face
now on the left is another
pre-industrial fetal skull
and on the right a very typical modern
skull
at around the same stage of development
notice the difference in profiles
notice on the right that retrognathic
growth the receding jaw
the smaller mouth all of the hallmarks
of a modern
obstructed airway again another modern
skull
and another you get the idea
our clogged airways and two small mouths
are now
heritable traits they are getting passed
down
and appear to be coming more pronounced
with every new generation
in other words most modern humans are
screwed right out of the gate this helps
explain why so many infants snore
why they suffer from sleep apnea and as
a result
why so many kids now are afflicted
with adhd and other chronic health
issues
they can't breathe and if they can't
breathe they can't sleep
and if they can't sleep and breathe
properly cognitive and skeletal
development
takes a big hit but i didn't research
the ever shrinking mouth
and human disevolution just to dwell on
the negative
i wanted to uncover the core underlying
problems of our breathing
so that we could understand them so that
we could better diagnose them
and do something about it so we could
find ways
of fixing our breathing and improving
our health
and luckily i discovered that so much of
this
disevolution in our mouths and airways
is reversible
there's a sweeping movement in dentistry
right now focused on straightening teeth
while also widening our two small mouths
so many patients with sleep apnea or
snoring even allergies and asthma
have had their issues go away once they
could breathe
normally again by widening the mouth to
the size
it was supposed to have been we can also
return
to that pronatic profile as an
experiment i wore a device that
stimulated chewing stress
and minimal palatal expansion at night
in an attempt to fix my own obstructive
breathing
after a year i developed about 15 to 20
percent more space in my airways
now the irony isn't lost on me with all
this how
odd it is today that we are using
industrialized
technologies to restore ourselves to the
way we were supposed to have been
hundreds of thousands of years before
industrialized technologies damaged us
but life is a paradox and what are you
going to do about it not all of us
need such procedures to restore our
breathing for some of us our airways are
just fine
we're suffering from other poor
breathing habits
due to other environmental factors like
polluted air
constant stress or poor posture
correcting these inputs is even more
simple
sitting and standing straight allows
more air to enter our lungs more easily
i found a researcher who'd actually used
breathing
to straighten scoliotic spines
these methods are now being used at
johns hopkins and other institutions
breathing through the nose has
innumerable benefits and today
up to 25 to 50 percent of the modern
population
habitually breathes through its mouth
this makes us
more susceptible to snoring and sleep
apnea
and various respiratory problems mouth
breathing actually impacts our ability
to think the solution here is even more
simple
just shut your mouth by breathing
through the nose we can filter air
heat it moisten it and condition it
we get 20 percent more oxygen in nasal
breaths than we do equivalent breaths
through the mouth so nasal breathing
also helps
protect us from viruses and other
pathogens
which is especially important today it's
really our first line of defense
with a bit more effort we can learn
breathing practices
to hack into our nervous systems to heat
ourselves
and to heal ourselves even more some
practices have been shown to blunt
or in some miraculous instances
effectively
cure a laundry list of modern maladies
like autoimmune diseases asthma and
anxiety
so none of this should really come as
too much of a surprise
the ancients have been writing about the
power of breathing for thousands of
years
almost every major religion and dozens
of ancient cultures from the greeks
to the buddhists the hindus to the
native americans celebrated breathing as
a medicine
indian yogis train themselves to
decrease the amount of air they take in
at rest
not increase it they'd adjust the air
coming in
through different nostrils to elicit
different physiological responses
the history of these practices goes back
around 4
000 years the ancient chinese wrote
seven books entirely focused on
breathing
all the bad things that would happen if
we did it incorrectly
and all the benefits of doing it right
the chinese called their system of
conscious breathing
qigong chi meaning breath gong meaning
work
or put together breath work a quote from
the dao
reads therefore the scholar who
nourishes his life
refines the form and nourishes his
breath
isn't this evident i think it's becoming
more evident now
just in the past decade hundreds and
hundreds of studies
are showing clear measurable benefits of
adopting healthy breathing habits
a quick search on pubmed shows more than
46 000 research studies
on how breathing affects the body and
the mind
this work is being done at top
institutions and the vast majority
the data is confirming what so many of
the ancients
have said for so many thousands of years
that how we breathe really is a missing
pillar of health
i only hope that this time around we
don't soon forget it
thank you very much for your time
[Music]